yeah welcome to this video d for dynamo
do I know this guy to check keeping Kira
to GM norms yeah I don't know the start
ok we have a ruler pass and he's playing
a sort of delayed exchange quite weird
form I mean not even waiting for Bishop
e7 Caleb done all kinds of stuff is
playable
yeah White has given up okay no he's
opening up the position always have a
hard time to to to to get all this k
yeah maybe it is a feasible option here
yeah the question is should i take it
yeah that's probably all right this one
okay would be really surprised if this
should lead to anything looks very very
equal ish
okay yeah what even if I this is dead
now or can go here quick h4 I can play
maybe maybe Bishop f4
yeah well everything's equal here
yeah i can try to play this on time of
course
yeah I'll offer a draw okay he's got too
much time obviously too much time on his
hands to just play stupid moves back and
forth
now I could have played Bishop c5 maybe
I know I didn't really pay any attention
cause I I mean this is just not not very
yet very interesting
would be to em of course he's got to see
form
not quite sure what am I even doing on
this move Bishop c5 maybe at one time he
even will find it Luke g1 yeah I take
you for the porn is a born Bishop g4 was
check all right okay
so Bishop c5 finally here he saw the
smooth yeah okay the problem is that g7
is always attacked
mmm sooo p.m. k want to want to play
with h5 h5 King f5 it's still a draw
probably
yeah because of this move
ok so the H porn the edge porn is Sir is
not too bad
yeah I probably cannot win this you
really tried hard to lose but it's
probably are still not enough
yeah that's no way to win this not quite
sure what he's doing really I don't
understand anything so I try to win this
so what
mmm
yeah we'll see three years cigana I mean
it's it's it's a draw in thousand ways
so there should be seven hour not sure
what yeah
time warning
being grown yeah I don't know I should
have one probably I mean after this move
but uh yeah it's still it's still a bit
tricky maybe yeah yeah he's got this got
a bit of call to play yeah maybe I
should have just taken c3 am I that's
also ruka three yeah yeah well i don't i
don't get why on earth is he playing
please this position here yeah thanks
for watching I got a call to sleep